docteur christian lehmann bonjour vous
êtes médecin généraliste à poissy vous
même si vous allez prendre très très
bientôt votre retraite vous est aussi
écrivain auteur de deux romans il ya eu
la tribu adapté par yves boisset au
cinéma l'évangile selon qu'un décès sur
votre métier comme passion si vous
saviez
et puis vous tenez aussi une chronique
sur libé depuis le début de la de
l'épidémie de l'aco vide
et puis après avoir mis sur pied une
consultation spécifique d'ailleurs sur
cette corrida à poissy vous plaidé
aujourd'hui pour un assouplissement des
conditions de vaccination alors on va
commencer tout de suite part ça il
semble que vous ayez été entendu que les
médecins de terrain comme vous et été
entendus parle par le gouvernement les
médecins de terrain et les élus parce
que par exemple le maire de ma ville car
nos lits lancé une pétition avec 200
maires divers droite gauche en dix ans
elle est à écouter de la même manière
qu'on s'est pris en charge et on a
réussi à monter les centres qu'ovide au
début du confinement sans attendre que
nous ont donné la permission et sans
attendre la grèce on est capable de
mettre en place des centres de
vaccination contre la copine même si
c'est une logistique qui est extrêmement
compliqué et que normalement c'est de
l'état que ça devrait descendre on un
état qui est très puissant à une haute
autorité de santé un ministère on a tout
ça et au moment où il faut mettre la
logistique certes complexe d'une
vaccination pour la population
on a des gens qui ont tétanisé qui
s'asseyent sur leurs mains qui regardent
le stock de vaccins s'en va il est là il
faut surtout pas aller trop vite c'est
pas comme si on avait une pandémie
camilla net à l'arrêt depuis neuf mois
on va regarder nos doses en étant fière
qu'elle soit là alors évidemment ça se
heurte à la réalité comme que je crois
que c'est la compil disait le real tu
sais quand on se cogne
quand on voit comment ça se passe dans
les autres pays et qu'on voit qu'en
france a au bout d'une semaine v
glorieusement vacciner 500 personnes ce
moment là le président de la république
nous dit que il a pris quelqu'un
un chef de logistique de chez mckinsey
enfin c'est du délire complet on a un
état ou bien on est un pays complètement
à la ramasse tentant dans un coin perdu
donc comme d'habitude c'est du terrain
que ça vient et on se retrouve coincé
sur des protocoles dont certains sont
utiles certainement mais qui sont qui
sont faramineux et qui sont perdre
énormément de temps
alors justement wii auront mis en a mis
en cause beaucoup la bureaucratie alors
les chiffres sont terribles dans les
derniers films c'était 2000 vaccination
en france contre 308 en allemagne et en
allemagne les gens protestent en disant
que ça va pas déjà assez vite
est ce que justement dans votre exercice
quotidien
vous avez vous avez été gêné par cette
bureaucratie française cocon qu'on
incrimine aujourd'hui dans la lenteur de
la vaccination
excusez moi pour ce qui est de la
vaccination puisque ne l'ont pas encore
commencé à vacciner
oui mais ça fait des années que le
métier que j'ai essayé de faire faire
une médecine générale de l'individu
s'est heurté à des vexations
administrative supplémentaire qui
n'était pas forcément a fonctionné et je
dirais même que ce qui a eu
d'intéressant je si j'ose dire dans
cette pandémie c'est que au départ dans
la mesure où ces gens qui tombent des
protocoles de 15 pages pour s'essuyer
les mains se sont retrouvés tétanisé
dans leur bureau avec un stop demo diom
et que c'est nous les soignants première
ligne des urgentistes et réanimateurs
les médecins hospitaliers les médecins
généralistes les infirmières les aides
soignants c'est nous qui sommes montés
au front de dire ce que j'ai fait quand
j'ai vu arriver le confinement c'est
prendre mon téléphone et appeler le
maire de ma ville
est ce dire qu'est ce que nous ensemble
on peut faire pour les 36000 personnes à
peu près de la halle à de la
municipalité et où l'a fait on l'a fait
avec les bonnes volontés on l'a fait
avec la réserve sanitaire on a fait on
l'a fait avec les agents de mairie
héééé et la rs et le reste a suivi parce
que ça venait du terrain là l'état et
totalement angoissé parce que il sait
pas parler aux français c'est pas parler
un langage de confiance or dans les
instituts de sondage cevipof etc qui a
la confiance des français parmi les élus
les élus locaux uniquement à 90%
et parmi le reste des classes de la
société en général l'hôpital et puis les
médecins viennent à peu près au même
niveau
en fait ça fait des semaines que les
gens me demandent et vous docteur qu'est
ce que vous feriez avec le vaccin et je
leur ai répondu au fur et à mesure pour
le moment non pas pour le moment je n'ai
que des données commerciales du
laboratoire puis j'ai eu les données
scientifiques et qu'on a pu les regarder
ensemble les disséquer avec des
collègues dans sept métiers qui ont pu
répondre à mes questions et je le redis
aujourd'hui si le vaccin était
disponible cet après midi je me ferai
vacciner cet après midi sans souci alors
justement cette c'est intéressant parce
que c'est vrai que peut-être que les
mesurer le retard qu qu'on constate
aujourd'hui les mesures ont été
annoncées fin novembre c'est à dire un
moment où il va un grand scepticisme de
l'opinion sur le vaccin
pourtant cet arn messagers c'est
absolument génial non sûr qu'on va se
retrouver à faire comme michel chevalet
comment ça marche
il ya les questions qu'on pose sujet de
la rn2 message et c'est mes docteurs
je comprends c'est pas idiot des
questions idiotes et je ne manque pas
ses docteurs en général un vaccin sam et
12 ans là ils ont fait un pari mais là
on se retrouve avec une pandémie qui
bloque le monde entier et on se retrouve
avec l'ensemble des scientifiques et des
médecins qui travaillent en virologie
sur la vaccination qui travaillent
ensemble en l'espace de choix une
semaine deux semaines le séquençage du
virus du
le séquençage du virus était connue il
était partagé avec tous les
scientifiques de la planète les gens on
travaille ensemble on n'est pas chez les
bisounours un évidement que les
laboratoires va gagner de l'argent mais
en dehors de cette bataille entre
laboratoires
il faut comprendre que les scientifiques
ont échangé des données ont publié
beaucoup se sont engueulés parfois sur
ce que signifiait les données qu'ils
avaient et donc on a j'ai envie de dire
le gène humain
l'ensemble de ces scientifiques qui
travaillent là dessus donc évidemment ça
va plus il ensuite
les procédures ont été respectées sur le
plan scientifique mais sur le plan
administratif les administrations
excusez moi se sont bougés les faits
c'est à dire qu'au fur et à mesure elle
lisait les documents elle attendait pas
d'avoir les documents à la fin et de la
même manière les laboratoires n'ont pas
attendu une autorisation de mise sur le
marché pour commencer à penser à
produire
ils ont commencé à produire en sachant
que ça pouvait être un parti n'avait pas
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché
donc une énorme quantité de
scientifiques travaillant tous ensemble
dans un but commun face à une pandémie
qui bloquaient la planète des sommes
d'argent considérables mises à leur
disposition par les gouvernements parce
qu'il en allait de la survie des gens et
d'économie des procédures
administratives qui a été respectée mais
qu'ils se bougent est rapidement des
usines de production qui allait vite
et alors une technique une technologie
qui est celle des vaccins rennes message
est qui permet d'affiner la technique en
l'espace de quelques heures ou quelques
jours
là où les techniques qu'on appelle
traditionnel plus anciennes nécessité
d'injecter certaines choses dans des
oeufs d'attentes que ça finisse extra et
donc été beaucoup plus longue
donc on est arrivé quelque chose qui
pouvait durer 10 12 ans à cette
technologie qui a été mise en place en
l'espace d'un an à peu près ce qui est
excellent mais il faut savoir qu'au fur
et à mesure des années là
durée pour refaire un vaccin avaient
diminué et par exemple pour ebola
beaucoup parler parce que ça fait très
peur mais en même temps ce années quand
l'afrique pas trop trop regarder pour
ebola la distance avait déjà été
extrêmement diminué
et pourtant il n'avait pas tous les
éléments qu'il ya ici l'ensemble des
scientifiques travaillant sur ce vaccin
et les gouvernements où sont les vannes
financières pour que la sauce yankee
fille puisse avoir accès à toutes les
machines dont il avait besoin pour
avancer le plus vite possible alors il
ya deux grands vaccin arn messagers ccp
isr et modern à sanofi travaille sur un
autre protocole et ce qui sera comme
vous le dites
probablement un peu plus long à mettre
au point l'urgence aujourd'hui c'est
quoi ce serait d'abord selon vous de
vacciner les personnels de santé parce
que c'est eux qui sont dans le combat où
un produit au premier rang je pense que
c'est extrêmement complexe à déterminer
et j'ai pas du tout vocation à dire que
j'ai la solution mais je vais essayer de
réfléchir avec nous pourquoi on a
confiné pour qu'on a mis le pays à
l'arrêt avec ce qui à mon avis était
nécessaire mais avec ce que ça entraîne
de souffrance morale de difficultés
financières de file pour certains on l'a
fait parce qu'on a dit on est au taquet
si on continue comme ça si on ne confine
pas les réanimations vont être submergé
il ya des gens qui mourront pas ce qu'on
peut remplacer du qe2 ok qu'est ce qui
se peut submerger l'erea aujourd'hui
éventuellement le fait que personne elle
tombe malade ya un énorme absentéisme
parce que les uns après les autres les
médecins les infirmiers les gens qui
travaillent après neuf mois de
difficultés d'avoir eu pour certains
travaillent avec des sacs en plastique
et des masques quand ils ont trouvé sont
épuisés il y à des contaminations chez
les soignants il me semble qu'il est
important pour l'ensemble de la
population de commencer à vacciner et
les soignants volontaire
j'ai presque envie de dire quel que soit
leur âge parce qu'on dit bon on va on va
vacciner les soignants qui sont âgés de
62 500 clés réalité c'est que dans
beaucoup
la réalité c'est que dans beaucoup de
services de réanimation d'urgence de
pneumologie les médecins les plus jeunes
sont allés au front et ont mis les
médecins plus âgés et éventuellement
dans des postes un petit peu moins un
petit peu moins exposée or ces soignants
plus jeunes ils ont des enfants ils ont
des conjoints ils peuvent eux mêmes être
vulnérable ou avoir quelqu'un
vulnérables dans l'eure dans leur
entourage
un parent dans la mesure où il sent ceux
qui sont le plus en danger c'est pas les
seuls j'oublie pas les livreurs les clés
scier les policiers etc
il ya plein de gens qui sont au contact
mais si on nous dit que si on a confiné
ce parce qu'il fallait éviter la
subversion des réanimations il me semble
évident que les personnels d'urgence
doivent être prioritaires parce qu'ils
sont au contact et probablement les
médecins généralistes les infirmiers
ausy ça veut pas dire qu'on peut pas
dans le même temps continuer le
développement de la vaccination en ehpad
mais le développement de la vaccination
en ehpad a été mis en place par le
gouvernement
à mon avis - par le fait que ces gens
étaient vraiment en danger que parce que
c'était un univers clos rector lequel le
gouvernement pensait qu'il n'y aurait
pas de problème est qu'on pourrait
commencer comme ça tranquillement ce qui
donne du grain à moudre aux complotistes
qui disent oui et après avoir tué
louviot rivotril maintenant ils vont
expérimenter le vaccin sur des cobayes
ce n'est pas du tout le cas
on essaie de protéger les gens qui
pourraient en mourir mais ça a été
tellement mal fait au niveau logistique
que parce qu'il faut un consentement
mais pas question de vacciner quelque 1
100 sont sans son accord et que souvent
une bonne partie des gens qui sont en
ehpad n'ont pas toutes leurs facultés
donc ils ont le membre de la famille qui
sert de personnes de confiance où ils
ont un tuteur ou curateur et les tuteurs
plusieurs jours après que ça a commencé
on fait une
grande lettre en disant ah ben nous on
prend pas on prend pas cette
responsabilité
c'est une responsabilité médicale on n'a
pas les moyens on l'a tous tous ces
organismes ont mis en place cette
procédure extrêmement l'eau sans jamais
se tourner vers les gens dont ils
auraient besoin disant voilà on va
demander à vous le consentement
éventuellement pour votre patience que
vous êtes d'accord
il est tout à fait cohérent que les
tuteurs 10 nous n'avons pas de formation
médicale c'est complexe pour nous de le
faire mais il aurait peut-être fallu
soit rendu compte dès demain matin
d'avoir fait semblant annoncer cette
vaccination qui donc n'avance pas
puisque les vaccins sont 107 disponibles
et on avait tout en claironnant ont
commencé par les ehpad à la fin de la
première ça fait 2 500 personnes
vaccinées alors il ya donc le loup
d'urgence pour les personnels de santé
pour le grand public alors par exemple à
poissy avec le maire karl olive
quel serait selon vous souhaiteriez
mettre en place c'est quoi tout dépend
de l'approvisionnement en vaccins
d'accord et moi je n'ai pas fait pas
mystère jeu ce que je dis c'est que
plutôt que de ne rien faire est de
regarder nos deux si vraiment on avait
500 mille doses la semaine dernière s'il
ya 580 mille doses qui doivent arriver
aujourd'hui on peut commencer à faire
des centres vacciner dans lequel on
vaccine les soignants on vaccine les
personnes vulnérables
les médecins généralistes peuvent
contacter certains de leurs patients
dont ils savent éventuellement qui sont
durables et mon père qui est bien et
volontaires les faire venir et commencer
à les vacciner
ce sera une logistique complexe pour
plusieurs raisons vous l'avez compris le
vaccin ne subsiste or de super rigaud à
-80 que pendant cinq jours il ya une
préparation à faire avec une fiole on
peut faire simple
voir si doses de vaccin le vaccin doit
être préparée méticuleusement il faut
pas taper par exemple dans la seringue
comme on fait parfois prendre les bulles
d'air parce qu'il ya des petites
particules de lipides autour de la rn
messages etc peuvent être brisé donc ça
à nécessite d'être vraiment de faire
vraiment attention on peut vacciner cinq
personnes géant médias dans le même
temps il faut avoir les bonnes aiguille
il faut avoir les bonnes seringue c'est
le cas partout et il faut rester quinze
minutes avec les gens voir si ça se
passe bien jusqu'à 2 rarissimes
il ya deux voies ricine cas de réaction
allergique que malaise comme il y en
avoir après n'importe quel vaccin top je
peux pas vous dire aujourd'hui sans
avoir été sur le terrain sans avoir
commencé où ça peut coincer je dis que
c'est quand ni allant en commençant
doucement à petit tout ce qu'on peut
commencer petit à petit vacciner un
certain nombre de personnes
voir ce qui coince améliorer les choses
au niveau de la chaîne logistique et se
mettre en route
on aurait pu penser qu'en allemagne
faire différemment avoir des gens qui
avaient déjà préparé tout ce qu'il
fallait et juste arrivé non il va
falloir si j'ose dire inventé la
logistique nous mêmes puisque l'état est
incapable de le faire alors on me
répondra oui mais on a déjà eu les
vaccinodromes bachelot en 2006 n'a pas
marché alors je vais donner la grosse
différence entre les deux en 2009
roselyne bachelot passe à la télévision
et dit vous serez vacciner en vaccinant
pas par vaux m
parce que vos médecins qui vous fait
confiance tout va lui ils sont
totalement un foutu de respecter la
chaîne du froid
d'accord et ensuite quand elle commence
la vaccination en novembre 2009 la
grippe h1n1 qui est arrivé dans
l'hémisphère sud en mars avril qui a
fait peur à tout le monde a déjà au bout
de quelques mois montré qu'elle était
moins grave que prévu je rappelle un
fait au début du mois de septembre les
anglais ont un prototype de vaccin
ils veulent l'essayer sur des
volontaires il ya plein de jeunes qui y
vont et on découvre que ces jeunes qui
sont en bonne santé qui ne se sont pas
sentis malades ont des anticorps contre
h1n1 c'est à dire que dans l'immense
majorité des 15 70% d'entre eux ont fait
une formation tome éthiques
à partir de ce moment-là évacuer les
médecins généralistes les infirmiers de
ville que les patients connaissent pour
une maladie qui n'est pas une pandémie
grave
évidemment ça a foiré aujourd'hui c'est
très différent
on a l'ensemble des pays du monde qui
ont été mis à l'arrêt on a une maladie
qui peut être invalidante et donner des
colis de laon qui peut tuer des gens
malheureusement parfois jeunes même si
c'est plutôt des gens âgés on a des
soignants ville qui ce sont deux mêmes
impliqués et qui ont créé des copies
drôme les centres kovy de sang pour leur
demande quelque chose et donc vous
souviendrez peut-être que roselyne
bachelot toujours est passé devant
l'assemblée nationale pour dire mais
c'est quoi ce pays qui a besoin qu'on
l'aide commence à les médecins n'ont pas
masqué prix pelouse qu'est ce qu'ils
veulent ils veulent qu'on leur apporte
sa dans une petite boîte
ben non ils n'ont vraiment de rien en
fait comment ne rien parce qu'on se rend
compte que vous êtes incapable dont on
va faire et on va faire ce robot est
alors dernière question parce qu'il ya
cette urgence évidemment urgence pour
l'économie parce qu'on sait qu'on perd à
peu près à venir chaque jour à cause de
ce virus
et puis il ya ce cette nouvelle souche
qui a contaminé semble-t-il l'angleterre
qui arrivent en france qui semble-t-il
plus contagieuse que la première est-ce
que ça d'abord c'est ce que ça ne gêne
n'aggrave pas la situation d'urgence
pour la vaccination
et deuxièmement est ce que on entend
beaucoup de médecins 10 recettes de
cette deuxième vague avec ce nouveau
virus va être terrible il va falloir re
confiné totalement et durement comme
comme l'a fait l'angleterre
quel est votre sentiment sur ces deux
sujets je ne sais pas et quand je ne
sais pas je ne dis pas je pense que de
ce qu'ont compris le variant angles il
ya plusieurs mutations souvent mais ce
variant qu'on appelle le variant anglais
qui n'est d'ailleurs pas avare et
anglais puisqu'il a été trouvé dans
d'autres pays afrique du sud il ya
simplement les anglais eux quand ils
font des pcr il faut aussi des
séquençages donc ils sont rendus compte
qu'ils avaient un variant nous on ne
fait pas ça nous permet de dire que
c'est que c'est chez les anglais mais il
est
déjà avant simplement on se rend compte
disons qu en europe il ya un nouveau
variant qui semblait légèrement plus
contagieux ou plus contagieux en
angleterre il n'y avait pas de
confinement les bars étaient ouverts les
restaurants que ça plus qu'un vaccin
un par un les risques de contagion s'est
adonné la situation là-bas d'explosions
qui nécessite de confirmer en france
c'est extrêmement dur c'est extrêmement
dur pour les restaurateurs c'est restons
extrêmement dur pour les hôteliers mais
tout ça c'est fermé depuis un moment
beaucoup de gens ont hurlé contre la
fermeture des cinémas et je les
comprends
le problème c'est que ça a limité quand
même un petit peu la circulation du
virus donc je ne sais pas du tout
comment ça va se passer quand janvier et
j'ai envie de dire c'est comme dans les
films catastrophes l'américain ce que
nous donnons des patries sait on est
déjà en alerte rouge est ce qui est un
niveau alerte et carla non alerte noire
de toute façon on est en alerte rouge
même s'il n'y avait pas eu ce nouveau
variant il faut essayer de vacciner
rapidement et de manière correcte et
cohérente
les gens qui sont volontaires les gens
qui sont remontés il n'est pas question
d'aller embêter les autres soit il ya un
effet d'entraînement parce que les gens
qui sont vaccinés qui l'ont bien seront
les ambassadeurs du vaccin mais en tout
cas il faut avancer on peut pas rester
c'est pas le problème d'être la risée de
l'europe
si nous on avait raison que les autres
avaient tort serait pas grave d'être la
risée l'euro c'est juste que ce
gouvernement ne sait pas faire du tout
du tout merci infiniment docteur
christian lehmann éclairage et donc on a
un espoir quand même c'est ce vaccin et
que les volontaires puissent se faire
vacciner ce serait ça serait une bonne
chose
je résume rapidement votre votre propos
merci beaucoup
christian les bains c'est moi qui vous
remercie revoir